so it's a yearly blitz arena I think I
played last year is it always March 13
starts in about five seconds I'll play
I'll probably play a decent player the
first game this is a six hour long event
of five in a chess let's play a London
this guy wants to bezerk divide the zerk
against him i'll beserk okay London time
I play the tournament the other day
which he just crushed this line is I
think considered nice for whites take
their Bishop d3 natural move I'll
include c3 and Knight b3 usually I like
to put the Queen on like each three both
let's build up a little bit of pressure
I'll throw in castling 95 I have to take
that put the rook on d1 and I think the
plan is not to get mated first of all to
play g3 and we'll feed Heather the Queen
threatening f4 maybe maybe not because
Queen takes III and now I'll bring the
bishop back and pressure the D pawn
wanna play rook d2 and rook F d1
in the meantime I don't know if I have
the chat open I do have the chat open
hello chat
how's it going Oh attack the pawn
another time I could do this we could
trade nights and then bring the Bishop
to b3 Oh
let's win a five looks like a free pawn
now I'll move back that was nice
play a3 may be preparing bishop a - oh
it's an interesting move let's play
Bishop c2 restricting the night might go
for this and this is attacking the rook
as well but the knight the rook was
defended by the knight the pawns not
defended so I'm winning material knife
f5 looks attractive if King me a queen
g8 wears a mating idea check maybe I'm
not mating but I'm up two pawns so the
positions good we could trade Queens
let's trade Queens and win another pawn
pawn can't be defended I could even
throw in Knight f4 do i let's take the
pawn first White's up three pawns we'll
trade rooks at least one pair of rooks
let's put the knight in the center and
then maybe let's play h3g for coming Oh
gave me another pawn which I should have
taken let's play King G - I mean I just
have to play quickly enough how these
speed things up very soon move the
bishop back when the pawn let's defend
the pawn restrict the Knights
attack the night restrict the night's
attack the night attack the bishop crash
for the minor pieces knife at five let's
take a night pretty sure I can win this
I don't want to give up and pawn but
that's okay
pretty sure I have enough pawns let's
just push well let's put the King on f3
first but I'll push this guy I'll go
after that pawn check and slowly but
surely
I'll make progress my king will be
sheltered I don't think there's any
stale matrix
now I just have to not stalemate the guy
with the bishop my technique is a little
bit bad but it's good enough I think
there you go okay five seconds left so
hello to people hello the ice hello
ronke hello Eddy 139 the real donkey
pride August Rosen Tomko P X 5 X 3
o'clock so many names life is good for
the time being please play a Kings
gambit it's hard to play Kings gambit
with black I could maybe play a budapest
gambit what's this guy's real rating and
it's bits from oh so Geo Thanks oh so
Geo this guy's very provisional let's be
careful I'll play qgd play this line
with h6 and Bishop f5 yeah this is one
of the main lines should be
approximately equal that move is kind of
strange
there should be four in there yeah
Bishop b4 check King has to move
somewhere and then maybe a five I want
to play
a4 a3 move the bishop back move it back
to e7 usually the knight should be on d6
I'm gonna go probably for this maneuver
or this maneuver ok so let's bring the
knight in I could attack the pawn
let's start with Knight c4 let's start
with my c4 p tix and it's two bishops
versus two knights thoughts on Marie
Lopez opening for a relatively new
player yeah Roy Lopez is very solid for
a relatively new player your main
priority should probably not be openings
but rather tactics and strategy okay so
I have the bishop pair play B 5 or a 4
first let's play B 5 first if a 4 I have
Bishop b4 maybe castling castling rook -
Yates he wants to play b3 so maybe a 4
is a move let's play for restricting b3
this is a solid set up in drafts they
call this a fork there's a lot of
tactics that can be generated with this
setup and drops but probably not in
chess okay I'm gonna play very tricky
move well you see my threat saw it we
could still put the bishop put the
bishop on and c7 on ith 5 could be
annoying than king e7 so a5 is
restricted getting ready to play rook to
e8 and then maybe eventually c5 there's
also ideas with Bishop d3 check and
stick the bishop in Wow
maybe rook g8 this is a half-open file
I'd like to organize some meaning attack
but how the other work here maybe move
the King over oh I forgot about that
move oh that's not good so I lost a pawn
that's not good at all wait I have a
trick if he plays oh it does it work
rook c1 no it doesn't work also he's
winning another pawn wait I'm just
getting crushed here
this is not good let's take the night
and play rook c1 and try and get some
miracle I'm down on time too I like the
position I just forgot that d3 could be
taken takes takes RB forth now this is
not pleasant looking for tricks and you
rip b8
keep both rooks on the board go for B
for next go after the b-pawn so White's
playing a little bit passively improve
the King both rooks tied down G for
logical let's play h5 trade off the pawn
down to pawns life could be better let's
attack the pawn again drama a plate
moves back to C - I'll move back to h5
I'm a bikini six coming expecting g4
here at three also solid let's move from
behind not sure if this is the best move
attacked from behind
Wow let's move the King this way I want
to win the b-pawn and save my a pawn
Brooksie to king b7 King b7 anyway
so takes have to go for this I'm trying
to pull off a miracle they're waking a
six takes rook b6 takes takes the Kings
not in the box let's trade rooks on the
trade when you're out material right oh
let's play King b5 preparing this move
if I draw this I'll be a massive miracle
oh that's a good move
let's move the king up it's not looking
so great though
I have one last idea ideas rook a five
certainly an idea okay five you might
take on a three then it's rook versus
four pawns yeah this is very dangerous
to bring back the king run like Forrest
Gump how that's a good move also a good
move check there there he Queens with
check though so there let's do this
now this player is underrated it's
unfortunate check there maybe you win
another pawn wait I might be surviving
maybe am i drawing this I might be
drawing this check and then I can take
yeah this is a draw that's why it wants
to play for a win okay I survived I was
kind of messy game drew a rook ending
how how many pawns was i down as down
three pawns the outside a pawn it helped
like white should be winning here even
in this position no maybe it's not so
easy King here I was gonna take pawns
cuz at first I thought it was gonna be
just dead lost my king can't get this
way but it came from behind you got just
with a hundred bits saving the saying
big save yeah okay so I'm undefeated on
top 50
there's over 1700 players in this
tournament that's a lot of players is
Lee chest attacking my stream stream
title me chest org update refresh
hey it's detecting my stream and a sub
from Night Moves 0 1 4 6 months nice
okay new game playing this guy let's
booze Erick and let's play aggressively
I'm gonna play staffer gambits because
why nots
can i play London system but I'm black
playing a four nights with Bishop e2
let's play a dubious Halloween gambit
because why not
Knight G 191 probably like at five I
can't complain with this like this is
what the Halloween gamete is all about
like a look at these terrifying pawns
would make a great Halloween costume
just like cover yourself in pawns
so the Queen here preventing Bishop g7 I
didn't want to take and give away any
initiative also I'm attacking b2 maybe
threatening this this interesting move
Queens attacking d5 this Bishop still
hanging I could take it maybe I should
just take this way opening up the Queen
so I have multiple ideas a lot of things
are hanging so Queen e2 maybe Knight d4
not winning material I'm just going for
a piece play piece activity is fun
sometimes Queen d2 is expected and then
I can take the knight takes Queen g6
looks fine there's gonna be some knight
g7 weird things or that what does this
move I play Bishop Bishop e3 doesn't
quite work yet it might work in the
future hmm
wait I don't have much time
I'm just Bishop 8 no maybe maybe this
move f3 though takes takes very soon
I'll pick up the pace I'll play this
yeah I'll take a little bit risky I want
a Castle queenside it takes maybe takes
no that looks way too risky
let's do this AHA but there's a knight
h5 Knight g7 wait this could end badly
okay that makes me very happy
now the king is safe I still want to go
for Bishop III at some point that move I
forgot about well back to being down
material okay there's still some
pressure
the Queen is tied down - see - I can
fork winning back material if Queens f4
maybe I play this first
wonderful night off four takes takes
Knight f3 that move let's retreat trying
to look for like Bishop III ideas I want
to chase the Queen to a square where I
can fork so if Queen before
that's a fine move I don't really want
to take throw-in a check first yeah my
time management is so bad let's take to
move much much quicker I like the
position I'm up to pawns
I'm down a ton of time I wanna play rook
e8 or maybe d4 at some point let's play
this move try and simplify also am i
winning material
how does white defend if 92 I just take
it oh let's do this everything's tied
down to everything not sure what my
thread is though maybe you just rook e8
19 seconds left and rookie it looks
logical but once the Queen trade let's
take this and now I'm winning material
17 seconds should be enough time when I
get this Bishop to a better place
probably on e4
yeah I just want to play simple and
quick moves and eventually build up some
attack okay everything's defended so I
can probably just start pre moving I'm
probably bring the king to e7 just to be
safe
eventually I'll lift the rook over cream
of this will you take my pawn no oh I've
dropped a rook what am i doing but he
didn't take it okay
things are okay still yeah 13 seconds is
plenty of time rook c3 maybe leveraging
the pins let's play Queen b5 and then
put the rook on d6 ok now I want to play
C 5 and then d4 that's a free Queen and
free mates next move
ok GG I should play quicker next game
especially if I desert make up some more
tea ok 6 th place I dropped places after
that game only 3 games so far could I
play a London system with Knight c3 sure
I'll see what happens g6 so London with
Knight c3 writes what's happening
let's play III and then I'll play this
kind of standard h4 h5 idea already
looking kind of fun
I'll take g6 is now a big targets h6 was
not the move to play I could take it and
then Queen h5 and then I'll wait out
five keep some initiative expecting a
six Wow
let's bring in the Queen and then bring
in the night I feel like this is a nice
mating square 95 is the plan Queen e8
let's check I definitely want to keep
Queens on the board put the Queen on h3
I still want to do this move Queen c8
could be in the air
Queen h2 could maybe be a move there
should be six doesn't move so many moves
let's check first Knight a four ideas
play nine a four there's so many nice
squares for all the pieces maybe Knight
h4 to g6 also these ideas I think this
type of position it's very important to
just be aware of the resources and have
options to choose from he wants to play
94 I don't play this can trade nights
now this night is kind of pinned to the
bishop bring the knight in
my opponent is defending but okay
weights to stop a pawn of Rick a7 is
unusual let's castle king safety first
there should be eight ok let's save the
queen
now each six is attacked so he defends
let's play play g4 trying to improve
bring the knight back bring the Queen
back I'm retreating but I'm about to
unwind with f3 or the night might come
to e5
did I miss a free rook I may have missed
something I don't know the chat always
knows best
ok h6 is attacked 95 is coming there's
bound to be free stuff maybe maybe Queen
h2 coming
expecting Queen yeah Queen here here now
there's ideas of this there's ideas of
this let's check that would be a plunder
let's take the Knights and do this maybe
g5 coming hmm maybe still g5 if takes I
take the rook if that okay this file
opens this guy's surviving and kudos but
whites up enough pawns now they're
talking for free maybe a positional sack
I don't know what that was
this d6 square is super nice Queen b6
could calm and then Queen g5 put the
Queen on g4 tack the pawn if Ricky eight
I play h7 if that let's just trade I
have them up like four pawns that's a
lot of pawns
mmm spicy for was there made into where
it was made into oh you're blind okay uh
let's go for want to checkmate the King
in the center of the board it's a little
bit difficult though
check check maybe I'll just do the
latter mates will climb down the ladder
yeah this way I can ladder mate from
both sides okay GG I'm struggling to
break the top fifty now it's taking a
while to beat some of these opponents
who's in first place 28 points while was
working everything have to do more
busier King and winning quicker okay the
golden boy 97 Alba Zurich and I'll play
a Stafford gambit again Knight f6 no one
wants to go into the petrov so sad so we
have a very symmetrical opening very
symmetrical this is a this is an
interesting line attempting to make the
game dynamic
but we might just be but with being
solid I don't know I should save my
bishop
oh but Queen f3 is an idea so maybe I
should play c6 we could trade if Knight
goes back I play this we're gonna trade
some more and it's probably going to be
relatively equal I do have slightly less
desirable structure f4 is very
interesting but I could take and then
Queen b6 and win upon maybe threatening
some fork
you know the bishop defends so let's
just take back ok blocks up a pawn and
not a bad position White has some
counter play my knight needs to fending
probably this move if rook e1 probably
f6 the ice has to do work have fun doing
work and Kiyomi in the chats
hello Kiyomi uh this should h4 so d4 is
an idea let's play Queen f7 extra safe
now if d4 I just take it also might be
sevens pawn my b7 pawn is defended so my
Knights not really pinned and I have
four ideas rook c8 ideas g5 ideas so
there's resources here sorry with her
creates some benefit of having these
double pawns extra half open file I
probably will play g5 at some point let
me start with rook c6 preparing the
double up
I have to watch out for Bishop takes e5
so the threats takes probably is a
threats so let's play this move I want
to go for g5 very soon
Dwight is just playing very like
passively just trying to survive
I probably means I have time to maneuver
I might start with 9797 okay here I'm
defending the pawn cuz I like this at
five square and the d4 square whoa does
this move it's still not at five another
five G 494 okay I mean King should still
be safe can I do this and be very fancy
there's Queen b3 check unfortunately but
I have this move preventing Queen b3 and
forking everything that's nice how many
people are at work right now
not doing work and just watching me or
trying to do work and multitasking like
watching me and pretending to do work
alright so but white resigns GG I'm top
20 now or how many people are at school
I feel like okay it's a morning on a
weekday at least most people in the US
should be at work or school
the fucsia says my work is watching you
it's probably technically true okay
let's play AE for mix it up a little bit
okay we'll have a Grand Prix something
new at least compared to the previous
games mmm let's castle first
how fancy do I want to be let's be fancy
this is a new kind of trendy line forgot
who played this it was like grease shook
Nepal Miyaichi someone played this who's
really strong an idea is that after
Knight takes d4 why it actually gets a
really nice position like really nice
it's just a gambit I think Knight takes
f3 Queen takes f3 and this is some
Grisha game I'm pretty sure an f5 f5 is
actually the improvement I was studying
this a few months ago and stockfish I
think gives f5 is like +2 but now I have
to remember what's going on I think I
just take and stockfish comes up with
this idea like g4 if Bishop takes or or
probably if Knight takes I won't win a
piece and the problem for black I'm also
threatening at 6 so there's really no
great defense here I was Grisha I'm VL
yeah I was like some speed tournament on
chess calm I'm white won the game like
in very nice fashion but I think the
white the way white played was somehow
not as good compared to this computer
always nice to unleash some preparation
drink some tea
Shoji for now it's still gonna take work
yeah black will have something I'll
probably put the bishop on that for
conceding the d4 square but that's okay
if 94 probably Queens you too very soon
I want to play Knight d5 very nice
outpost the problem for black after
trading off light squared bishop light
squares are very much in whites control
yeah Asics is an idea maybe I'll start
with like rook d1 just allowing b5 now I
play Bishop g5 a tempo probably this
move starting to smell some tactics like
the rooks a line d6 pawn is backwards my
take c5 in the air Bishop a line with
the rook yeah this position smells like
tactics
so I think one difference between like
stronger players and just amateur level
players is developing a sense of smell
so rookie Yates rookie 8 what to do
Knight g5 maybe I mean I could take on
c5 perhaps I can see five takes takes
takes takes takes mmm there's also
taking on d6
which is really interesting promise
Bishop d4 Intermezzo then rook takes
what is this line it's also Bishop g5
interesting wait a minute Bishop takes
f7 takes Knight g5 some other main ideas
takes takes Knight g5 if King g8 I just
made if King f6
queen and c3 looks good enough if King
e7 can probably just take on d6 Oh take
on g6 Knight takes c6 Queen f7 I have to
go for this this looks so much fun so
much fun there's a potential Queen sac
it's actually so beautiful because I
suck a bishop the slime King takes
Knight here here I suck another bishop
and then I suck a queen and then it's
made in the end I think wait does it
mean an end
pretty sure it's made in the end please
play King e7
I mean what else does lock do is I guess
there's for legal moves if King f8 I
just take on d6 because the knight would
be pinned and yeah f king g8 have the
classic like some other mating idea I
think earlier I had said Queen b3 but
that would run into c4 so a good thing I
have Queen d5 there's also this line
here here here
my queen would be attacked by the bishop
because I can take if Knight takes and I
take the bishop with meat so King e7 is
it gonna happen just making sure I mean
black has two legal moves again please
just play Knight takes g6 such a nice
finish
yeah if King g7 I mean I just take the
rook Bishop g4 I probably just take it
then Queen d7 should be mating in the
end Oh Queen takes I forgot that was
legal completely forgot that was legal
so there were three legal moves well I
could take a queen
maybe Queen this looks good enough I
think the night at the Queen the rook
the time situation is that hammer in the
chest let's hammer in the chat hammer
knows what's up
yeah I mean kind of wish my opponent
went down in style
probably just show it in analysis void
for satisfaction afterwards what's the
quickest way to win this rookie one I
could take maybe uh uh check check I
think this is meaning unless it's not
meaning I forgot there's King d6 wait no
this is mating rights if king c8 oh no
it's not meaning but it is flagging oh
let's check this is honestly not the
best technique the ninety six will come
and now check yeah I was just
disappointed that I couldn't have like
sacrificed all my pieces because it
started with this Bishop sacrifice and
then another Bishop sacrifice and then
it could have been a queen sack at the
final position being like this but a win
is a win
back to tournament I'm in 17th place 19
points the leader has 31 points
let's blizzard I'll play another efore
wasn't a pretty funny for game someone
wanted King's gambit earlier so I'll
play King's gambit I honestly don't
really know much theory beyond Bishop c4
I've just been playing it against like
lower rated players recently it's
offered decent results Wow his other
move that looks like a move let's take
on f7 first and take probably this is a
problem with not playing an opening that
I knows and my opponent is good enough
to be more prepared than me I'm gonna
try and win back this pawn might be
difficult I want to bring the knight to
d3
so at least I have some purpose i'll so
i'm controlling e5 g5 what a move
so what to do have to develop could put
them out in e5 right away and I think
I'll do that if I want to be very brave
maybe g3 looks weakening though so he
wants to trade nights let's go in with
the Queen anything better oh this is not
a fun position to play so I have to
prove something maybe Knight g4 no okay
what's going with the Queen I probably
want to play g3 at some point if I have
a chance I try and break up the pawns
there is neither oh no there's not I
have six because I take on g5 okay so
we'll get this line expecting Queen e8
plays Bishop f5 I want to take on f4 but
that would be bad
so g3 how bad is this takes takes I
didn't see anything that worked so I'm
just gonna put the rook in the center
I'm so low on time
I have bishop takes off for ideas though
should have probably considered that
let's attack the rook
if rookie a queen of 7i Rokia king a
queen up seven King h8 where's my wind
King h8 okay so he does that so I can
take in the night East seventh or Knight
takes c6 or Knight takes c6 right away
even better look at all these things
attacked and I've takes I fork the the
things and I'm winning g5 to okay this
is maybe turning around just maybe I'm
forking the things triple fork with a
bishop
we need a fork fish of emotes okay so I
could take here with check first and
then we might be trading Queens and then
I'll win the exchange and then let's
invade with the rook yeah this should be
easy
oh wait I have 28 seconds maybe slightly
challenging a little bit but they work
on c1 or just take a pawn okay I have to
put the king or maybe I'll invade on a C
file oh that's gonna be annoying check
check
if rope g6 I force to rip trade and if
that I take take on a seven I have like
meeting ideas I want to push the a or
beep on at some point
ah he can oh wait no okay well this was
just winning push the pawn to b5
maybe I'll just bring my king in yeah
the opening kind of went terribly wrong
but the endgame is going right uh check
wait I don't know if I have although
Queen turned on I want to promote
tonight okay this is just me like I was
about to take I'm pretty sure I do have
all the Queen turned on and that was
have been stalemate I know there's a
trick you hold down like alt or control
I didn't want to risk that this is a
nice force mate though because if King
takes I do this and then it's just mate
next move do I miss me than one or is
made in one
what was it earlier well maybe I had
earlier with the rooks I don't know your
rook takes h7 is illegal and if it was
leave it would be bad here so okay back
to tournaments yeah 10 seconds is enough
time for several moves especially if
it's endgame because pre moving doesn't
waste any time
so there is an art to to the pre move
takes you 24 seconds to do the latter
meet to practice your ability to climb
ladders okay I'm not gonna beserk let's
play a London because why not
b6 okay what to play play c4 let's play
92 yeah this is a fun line a lot of
players will allow this line unknowingly
I read a crush fell into this line and
the US Women's Championship and just
like walked in actually she played I
think Bishop d6 which is the best move a
lot of people will will prevent Bishop
b5 and just allow Knight g5 such a nice
variation and z purple blazer thanks for
subbing do you appreciate that so I'm
guaranteed to win f7 I could take it
right away
oh there's Bishop b4 check but then c3
maybe I'll just take back blacks still
can't defend I do go over this trap in
my London course and as far as I
remember whites supposed to take with
this might now you take with a the
center night because this nights very
key in attacking e6 when Queen has to
move
and then after I take the rook I think I
can probably save the night I'll just
come back
okay so black wants to win something
let's do I mean c3 c3 Brooke c1 looks
solid uh yeah I did go over this in a
st. Louis Chess Club lecture to the so
called Ashwin trap the Grandmaster
Ashwin Jayram has had this trap like two
or three times in tournament play twice
in the same tournament again it's like
feed a masters that's one of these
opening traps that like strong players
fall into for some reason where it can
we check it type in my name and London
into Google and it should come up I
think the the video has like a quarter
million views or something I was back
when I back before I had a YouTube
channel Bishop here or Knight f7 maybe
907 so White's just up a full rook this
Bishop moves backwards could develop and
now II five is very much in White's
control
so Doc's trying to go crazy create any
sort of complications so if I move back
then I lose a ruck I could throw in some
check yeah let's throw in some check
I'll probably move the bishop back to D
to be one at some point
Wow okay let's just take and castle king
safety first
Queen h5 on the horizon rook e1 still
present work b1 he's gonna do this this
and attempt to this let's take a pawn
Queen b3 coming hitting the bishop
hitting the e6 pawn ok Queen b3 would be
bad
I could play c4 maybe looks nice
Kiyomi thinking queen g4 also playable
okay doctor tournaments I'm in top 10
I'm in the top seven seventh place 28
points now 8th place let's beserk I
don't think I've lost a game with
Sherman oh I lost to this guy in the
past let's play Stafford gambit maybe
complicated position critical moment ok
playing this line he declines the gambit
a lot of people play Knight f3 not
realizing that I played knight c6 or any
tactics here not yet let's just to
reinforce the Knights but the bishop on
f5 and then Queen d7 coming hello - star
minion new name always new names every
stream if c4 I probably have an IP for
actually c4 I have Knight takes f2 as a
bishop would be undefended it's a nice
trap the same thing with apply was c3 if
c3 I have my choice of this or this so a
3 and let's mmm let's play a 5 actually
no I should not have played 85 and now
he's falling into the trap
I should have allowed b4 because I would
have had nights here but too late maybe
night here attacking the pawn if 95 I
can just take it or play Bishop d6 oh
you're from YouTube makes sense a lot of
people are from YouTube I'm gonna win
back the pawn everything's going pretty
well I'll take the rook if he wants to
take my knight or maybe I'll take back
Queen b3 let's play nice f4 attacking
the rook the rooks kind of trapped only
safe move is this but I can't take right
away maybe a for the Queen's tie down to
the fending now I just win the Knights
Gigi I just break 2400 I just broke 2400
I'm top three five points away from
first have not lost a game
Akio means leaving by Kiyomi
have fun watching Fleetwood Mac marathon
okay so I'm playing this opening
we're playing another one of these lines
copycat variation yeah I had this line
earlier earlier my opponent played nine
h4nh we're here is fine
ninety six is a main move I also showed
this line is in a st. Louis chess club
lecture showing how the double pawns can
be good now I have to be a little bit
careful
I honestly don't know too much theory
here maybe maybe takes an f5 to remember
preparation now five it takes take some
King H its weight takes takes f5 Queen
h5f four even there's ninety five ideas
so I could I could trade everything and
then playoff five make some sense I just
want an endgame
and keep it very positional so there is
queen g3 check King eh eights and I'll
be ready to play rook g8 if one wants to
avoid the Queen trade with this or this
and I have f4 okay so we're trading
Queens and it's bishops of the same
color which means I want my pawns on
dark squares I might play a four very
soon but I'm happy keeping the tension
c5 is interesting let's play c5
all right c5 if Bishop e3 I think I play
c4 and give him triple pawns it's kind
of a pawn sack but that's a positional
sack expecting Bishop takes if pawn
takes I probably play like rook c8
and put the rook on c5 I was not
expecting that move what does that move
takes takes takes takes mmm interesting
move maybe takes and rook c8 and I'll
try and win c3 thread is d5 I can take
on c3 Bishop c4 still d5
play a four I'll try and trap the bishop
I can win a pawn maybe takes on a seven
I still went upon Oh am i losing a piece
that's not good okay I can lose exchange
that's terrible
let's take and save the bishop okay I'm
down material I'm playing a good player
too maybe put the bishop on c6 this is
not easy to win for whites especially at
the time situation I think I'll still
put the bishop on c6 go for this i
blundered upon what am i doing not good
let's do this
stay calm I have to play better moves on
what I've been playing let's do this I'm
gonna try and transfer the Bishop to e6
maybe not have to play b6 bring the King
maybe in to d6 expecting work h4 that's
a good move - so tack the pawn and then
taking d6 in king c5 rook f5 I can play
Keaney here and maybe f5 not a bad move
BS 6 or do I play play this first
I'm very hesitant to play f6 can move
the king back now I should defend the
pawn though not pretty I have to make
use of the D pawn I don't want to trade
off everything to play this maybe this
coming chop the rook oh it's pinned no I
think I'm gonna lose this so sad
check attack the rook I won't resign yet
if I keep my rook on the board I won't
resign
still made me please
still not resigning let's play this okay
now I resign good game that was rough I
just blend I played Bishop takes g3 and
I blundered a piece and I blundered upon
later not a great game almost assail me
trick at the ends though now I'm playing
we took last time I played okay let's
bow I wanted to berserk I saw I played
we took he fell into London preparation
okay we're playing the same line as last
time see if he does anything differently
he played 97 last time when he played b6
here he's probably oh he hasn't learned
his lesson
this is whatever recommends for black
but as far as I know it's just a bad
line for black takes okay
ah h6 so maybe this is playable I think
I'll play this and go for g5 King side
attack
maybe g3 here restricting the knight
some point maybe Queen b1 or Queen c2
or Queen e2 and this looks like a very
very nice position I could even play g5
how to do so many nice-looking options
g5 ah there's some cool line I'll start
with Queen c2 if Knight here then I play
g5 and if takes I think it's made after
this in this
meanwhile at night I mean if the nine
most h8 I made immediately that'd be
nice okay let's take I think this is
fine I could take on h6 even be up to
pawns rook should be okay let's move
back bring the rook to h5
yeah that's a move
maybe rook h4 pretty soon I'm gonna
queenside castle try and ring the other
rook in take sticks that's interesting
takes I've rook e1 in the end I think
that works
calculating takes takes Knight takes e5
and then rook e1 and I'll win back e6 if
King g5 okay there's that move so we
also play Knight e3 interesting so I can
take I have 95 Intermezzo 96 Intermezzo
that's a little bit fuzzy maybe just
this move
I still 93 also takes there there Knight
g5 there
not seeing anything super clean me maybe
just rookie to keep all the pressure
probably a good practical move cuz he
force still attacked try need to take it
oh I don't have do I I completely forgot
about that okay let's run this way not
the most impressive technique
okay the bishop still attacked and it's
kind of stuck
I think I'll win a pawn back better one
appalling back maybe oh he wants to play
Bishop d3 Wow
so I could take and play rook e3 whoa I
was not expecting that knight c6 ideas
dog is getting excited let's play f3 win
back the pawn maybe this move whoa we
have to be very careful
everything's so slow for me
oh wait 96 if it takes off three I fork
let's take it's still tricky my night
gets kind of stuck he's playing this
well yeah I have to go for the dirty
flag
I have pawns though decent number of
founds its attack let's do this
attack the b-pawn improve the king over
h5 Wow let's do this
I might actually lose this that would
not be fun
no rook takes I win oh that was so dirty
that was really dirty
to be fair I was gonna promote man
I completely collapsed there I froze but
then I was so bad that's why to hold on
to your pawns till the very end
okay I'm in sixth place I've only lost
one game feels like I've lost multiple
games playing Enberg berserk play this
move I'm sorry if viewers threw up in
their mouths it's part of chess let's
play c4 I'll play Knight c3 I was
probably the best technique I've
displayed in a while I want to do
something maybe just each three not sure
if I want a castle like which way
maybe g4 or maybe even this move I'm
trying to win h7
g4 here okay I'm going all out for an
attack training this that's a move let's
play this attacking the pawn if this I
probably take wait a minute
I can take anyway if Bishop takes it's
this is main and - or no it's not
because he has King f8 it was almost
made into if King h8 oh he just resigns
Wow okay that was nice slightly cleaner
than the previous game I'm in fourth
place I'm gonna try and at least take
over first for a moment I'm trying to
break 2,400 again rated 2398
Oh was a lot of four is there for a
moment I'm playing the same guy let's
beserk he beat me last time time to get
revenge let's play a Sicilian I'll play
what I normally play okay let's take c4
okay so this is a line let's play let's
play e5 I'll put the Bishop on c5 maybe
throw in h6 preventing Bishop g5 um I'll
take do this
let's play c5 fix with structure d5
shouldn't be too much of a problem
hopefully the knight b5 could be
annoying yeah rook t8 let's play this
and maybe I don't know what I'm doing I
have to defend somehow this turn is kind
of awkward if I can get the bishop to c6
life will be okay hey life is okay now
I'll take it now I want to get the
knight to d4 and have a good night
versus terrible bishop yeah this is
looking nice he wants to win a 5 let's
defend it and then Knight d4 is coming
let's move the rook
maybe I'll go for a 4 try and create
some weaknesses
put the rook on d6 probably pay for
coming
if I plays a four I just win b3 might
win b3 anyway Wow
just resigns didn't want to fly on okay
I'm in third place who resides in that
position it was equal material could
have been a fight all right
third place six points behind the lead
I'll beserk I'll play e4 and let's play
don't want to play let's play a Spanish
play something mainstream play mainline
b5 he's gonna play Bishop c5 or no okay
so we'll transpose into theory and now
d4 pet line not the most common move
play c3 here Bishop g4 is a mainline
then I'll play Bishop e3 95 I can I just
take that I'm waiting upon it might be
winning a pawn okay we'll trade I'll
take the Queen first and then take the
bishop b7 f3 oh he can take cuz back
ring mates but now f3 Bishop d6 is still
a bit weird I think it's okay Bishop d6
Bishop f4 I'm holding on and if rook e8
like I have night d3 if Bishop c5 King
f1
okay let's put the bishop and the knight
kind of get stuck Bishop f4 maybe yeah
buck should have some compensation I'm
not sure how much but definitely a
little bit because two bishops I do have
the G for square for the knight now
which is actually quite nice yeah then I
can kind of walk its way around the
problem is Bishop d6 and g3 is kind of
tender don't play Bishop d6 okay f6 is
what I like to see still tricky though
maybe b4 see where the bishop moves and
now let's do this
if d2 i have Ricky to
okay we can leave the tension
I mean blacks dominating the D file but
I'm dominating my team safety maybe
might be one coming attacking the rook
the retreating us hacking move yeah cuz
the Knights not doing anything on e3
okay that's what I like to see I'm gonna
fight for the file take with night if he
takes ooh forgot about that move good
thing I have this move I was almost a
punch to the face free pawn looking kind
of scary your key eights let's run and
try and hide maybe King c2 coming yeah
King C to b3 coming I'm up two pawns and
two nights for two bishops I'm also
maybe having ideas like if rook here I
do stuff if so let's wait Ricky to rook
d2 and Gaul is okay let's fight for the
file bring in the night okay now I feel
happy it's a free bishop those bishops
too strong those bishops were too strong
until they were to hanging okay I'm in
second place I'm playing a high beserk
tell me chats no I'm not gonna do zurk
let's play Knight f6 and Budapest
because in Hungary they pronounce the
esses like I think because I have a
friend named Dennis and it took me a few
years of knowing him until I realized
his name is actually Denish hard to
adjust okay
I want to win the pawn and I want to
I've given lectures on this line we're
like in the middle game I want a rook
lift
well Queen II d5 Queen d5 is a move
let's prevent b4 and then just take the
pawn
there might be 94 at some points okay
let's castle so the queen is just being
weird on d5 I'll just ignore it
just continue development I'm not sure
how they get rid of it I might take on
f3 soon that's the move probably have to
play d6 and maybe Bishop e6 will come I
think there should be six Queen moves
and maybe I'm slightly more happy get
Bishop e6 Queen f6 is a move that hangs
upon maybe takes let's mmm take take
takes be seven rook b8 and I have time I
didn't beserk take a little bit of time
here
I know Bishop e2 is coming next I want
to go for this line that doesn't look
too writes maybe a 4 a 4 is actually
positional is before but should be six
maybe Bishop e6 right away yeah so my
queen isn't tied down has a bit more
mobility a4 is on the horizon just
undermine the pawn chain a now c4 is the
target
we could trade on e5 a little bit that
seems like a nice position
I have to thank Eric for inspiring my
opponents to play the Budapest against
me is that a good thing I mean if you
know what to play against this opening
its pleasant for whites like to play the
Budapest at a high level you have to so
learn some pretty intricate lines ok so
there's still issues white might play f4
f4 probably Knight g4 talking with Han
it's still a question how white deals
with this pawn break so we're trading
[Music]
it's one approach before yeah so if see
696 right here c5 there's a c7 I think
that wins a pawn so night there okay the
bishop back I have the bishop hair ideas
of this the threat is to just win c4 or
to attack Queen each three this is
probably coming or that but now c4 hangs
how's my goal all along so mission
accomplished but it's still a fight I'm
gonna fight for the D file yeah this is
nice now the rook can't access d1
anymore so now I just dominate the D
file
like this is a nice combo I'll play g6
preventing any queen invasion that's a
good move because this and this are
ideas maybe g6 was not so great I could
play I don't know what to play there's a
b6 maybe if Knight c5 I trade you can
soon I want to play this and maybe this
hmm yeah be about this h4 let's play h6
night c5 I'll take it okay so I'm up
upon I want to control the D file do
this
you also play Bishop h3 which is
annoying so I don't want to lose
material maybe this now there's ideas of
this and this which is actually kind of
hard to stop because why can't access
these two squares for the rooks so b5 is
illogical I think we'll just take and
play probably this coming try to rock
here we could trade don't really want to
trade we'll trade on this okay so I'm
losing b7 but I think I'm winning f2 or
a3 a3 could be a valuable pawn is there
a Mike static we know if the audio is ok
I need to upgrade microphones at some
point I'm doing this going after this
rook f1 expected also going for this I
think I'll just take your first nothing
to worry about
let me g5
my computer fan is very high move my
computer a little bit back sometimes
that has some effects with the sound oh
maybe my phone is too close move the
phone away okay it's time to push up on
until the Queen's a fro k7 I think
Bishop c4 and rook c1 my dog's excited
might have this plan to wait let's not
drop a pawn
oh let's start with this move okay I'm
gonna put the rook back preparing this
or this play a3 first now let's move
this way it's kind of annoying let's
move this way let's move back here takes
trying to calculate let's just do this
simple enough and then take the pawn
and this should somehow be meaning I
think check check check
checkmate okay back to tournaments I'm
in third place Clem so of hos is leading
with 58 points close behind I don't
think I'll play the whole six hours
we're only an hour and half in playing
Meg nag Dee high rating I'll try and
play solidly do I play against this
maybe this I forget any sort of
preparation here I'm just gonna play
normal moves I can take I do remember
something like the pawn goes here and
black is supposed to just play very
patiently maybe be five not the most
patient move I mean that my knight can
come in to bring the knight in first I
want to bring the night like f8 hey I
broke 2,400 now I'm gonna try and break
2500 I don't think I played too many
high rated players wow this is gonna be
sharp my King side feels very safe at
least for the time being I want to do
this and trap the Queen almost works
ninety-six nine years of 96 h4 here's
Queen b6 play Queen b6 actually not
entirely sure what the plan is just
trying to scare him a for know maybe
actually maybe the plan is this Queen to
b4 and then now I'm threatening a4 and
a3 can't be played because I just take
the bishop
if I get a4 a3 that would be very nice
because I have the only darks for a
bishop on the board so I want to create
darks where weaknesses this looks very
tempting takes takes and then a for
Bishop see to a3 b3 so tempting wait a
minute there's no attic takes takes
Queen B 5 and there's Knight c3 hmm
there's also this immediately there are
options here probably spending too much
time that's so interesting takes takes a
4 goes back a 3 B 3
not seeing it maybe I should just keep
the tension but f6 is a target Bishop e7
the move not so desirable it takes takes
gotta move much much faster okay let's
play Bishop e7 not what I wanted but
this is still looming this is probably
coming at some point maybe this move
coming to my opponent leaves a game left
the game now he's back and he plays
instantly d5 let's take or do I play
I'll take first maybe a for coming I
left the game again what is this stop
going away okay now this move
there's rook d4 that's okay bishops each
I have Bishop e6 t4 yeah a queen or
Queen b6 Bishop c2 Bishop e6 there's 96
on the horizon ah it just grabs a pawn
let's I mean there's counter play though
rooks are connected they file opening
probably has some benefit for me let's
take this way and take this way I can
still safe I'll have some attack just
got to play fast
I'll put the Queen here ideas of this
and also this can I get the b-pawn
rolling that's a good move
I have to support the b-pawn so you're
gonna play a for a for Queen b7 maybe
even Queen a hate a for Queen a it's
funny move left the game again maybe
internet connection issues that happened
to me when I was in Africa I was playing
on like less than one megabit per second
like upload speed and download speeds
what country doesn't say the country Oh
Queen a maybe it's a weird square for
the Queen but I'm pressuring the night
I'm threatening this if I get be foreign
I think I win material that's probably a
good move let's move back with the
bishop trying to stay alive I still want
to push
oh he's threatening to take on a six and
win immediately how do I defend that is
there any defense I don't see I need
offense maybe were there my gosh what a
strong move that's insane
how do I defend King here I have to play
off five only move I think
sacking another pawn I'm just trying to
hold on for dear life down to pawns
my queens in the corner really almost
nothing defending my king
just the shield of pawns 38 no routine
runs in tonight of 6 I'll probably throw
in King h8 er h6 when I have the chance
g 6f 6 is a probably a good move there
ok at least my dark squares can be
defended by the bishop h5 s good move
not looking good like how do I survive
this oh this is so difficult
the problem is h-file is just going to
be exploited now use haven't I take it
seemed a little bit weird please play
rook h1 Wow ok after this move maybe I
win the pawn ok so I'm still kind of
alive but I have 11 seconds left I have
to defend 45 yeah if 8th for now ok do
this five high five is nice let's take
and push the Jeep on let's start pre
moving stuff
maybe here oh no I'm not in time
okay now ah but he Jackson defends
that's so sad
gee pawn did not last oh he was
attacking my rook well played
yeah Queen g3 was super strong because I
can't really defend this um this might
have six threat I just don't have any
resources really like g6 I lose FX tough
game I'm in third place
well leaders oh he's leading the
tournament - what did you mg a PR lot
slapper zerk Kings Indian attack
I play the Kings Indian attack I think I
can against the caro-kann right yeah
I'll play Kingston the attack good
timing
I played efore but like this is a kind
of typical Kings Indian setup and how
does it usually go like usually this
right and you you actually try and
attack like the name doesn't really lie
oh that's a very good sign
so pawn restricts the Knights I think
the attack usually involves like h4
removing the night around putting the
Bishop on f4 maybe start with Knight f1
and then this move and then this move
now the pawns defended I want to play
something to attack each 6 BC 3 if d4 c4
I might want to play d4 soon as John
Davis come at that's a great command
let's play Knight H - what kind of tea
do I drink wait h5 g5 which I sack that
looks fun but also slightly risky how do
i crop the crack the position h5 g 5
takes takes Bishop b4 what's the play I
think I'll start with a four dog is
barking my dog heard a dog command a5
maybe let's play tricky - might have to
slow play this like slowly but surely
improved that's a good sign now black
has no way to open the Queen side and
all of the focus will be on the King
side Bishop h3 I'm tempted to take and
play g4 and like have the Queen just be
stuck there's f55 g5
that's a funny idea and now the idea is
very simple I just want to do this this
and this and trap the Queen
so looking the Queen escape I probably
can or maybe I don't know I was thinking
h5 with Alex into Knight g5 and of this
I do this I no longer have this eventual
rook g3 idea but I have this in this oh
he's stopping Knight g5 I still have
this I'm pretty sure I'm chopping the
Queen the Queen went into deep can't get
out and the knight on e6 is tied down to
the g5 square there is a smooth Bishop
h6 but then I think I just play queenie
one can even take on h6 but that would
just trade so what's this line Bishop h6
Queen e1 I have for a knight g1 oh wait
a minute
my queen side down to D 3 so Bishop h6 I
okay never mind queen is just trapped
I should probably play Queen d1 here so
beautiful
yeah another four I mean I maybe I
shouldn't take it let's just take the
Queen how that night is kind of stuck I
can I take good take let's take the
bishop I'll have enough material there's
about four of g1 so black is trying to
fight Europe g3 first I want to play h5
but I want to be ready to meet Rocky
Jade's so h5 first others takes and rook
it's kind of annoying let's play this
defending h4 some plan of this and this
there's also plans of like f4 f5 which
could be very very nice let's play I
mean I'm in no rush let's do this
and now let's push because why not ready
to play off five after f5 the G files in
open okay he just resigns GG I'm in
fourth place the first place guy paused
I'm about 11 points behind the pack that
was a fun game thanks for the opening
recommendation you got chess and things
for the hundred bits to do appreciate
this I don't believe Carlsen is playing
I mean who knows maybe I played him
unknowingly maybe I played him maybe
he's a guy in second place currently uh
thanks for the more bits 500 bits I have
to play the Kings Indian attack more
often am I gonna play the Stafford gamba
against this guy he's higher either than
me I'm just playing a trash opening he's
thinking okay moment of truth we'll see
what happens
Bishop e2 do I go crazy let's go crazy
this is objectively not the best move
it's the most fun move F M stands for
feed a master F IDE and feed a stands
for some kind of French acronym what do
I play here Queen D for was a queen d4
Knight g4 and goodness longest
continuous stream I've ever done was
nine hours is for this marathon
tournament it's on YouTube type in my
name and marathon and maybe you'll find
it yeah this is a type of position this
great great opening for blitz cuz okay
White has to think and I prepared this
at one point with the engine I just have
to remember what the engine said I think
it says White's winning but it's hard to
refuse
and the threat is very simple like I
just want to take on a for around five -
why did I say that for I want to take on
F - I said F for cuz I was just
calculating the line Queenie one here
and then like Bishop takes wait was i
calculating I don't know what I was
calculating F for is illegal in so many
lines because the pawn is pinned so he
plays ninety-two wants to play D for us
pretty soon I have Queen Queen b6 or
Queenie 526 takes Queen g 6d for takes
takes probably doesn't work like Queen
f6 takes takes Queen f6 seems most
practical d4 takes takes the bishop
takes on G - looks good enough there's
this line here here here here here Queen
f3 and then I think I'm just winning
because rook h1 is unstoppable
okay let's go for it
I don't think I'll take the bishop be
very surprised if he does then again
what else does white do I want to take
on g2 if g3 I have Queen f3 g3 Queen f3
Knight f4 and then each two mates that's
nice so I'm keeping some time advantage
I don't actually know what white does
here if he can't I mean he can't really
play g3 can't take the bishop
I don't think shouldn't take the pawn
otherwise like any other move I just
take on g2 can we Zion good flag it
close his eyes and pretend that's using
a happier place
okay e5 that's a move
can I take probably not Queen g6 was a
move but the nine f4 I mean I could
still very much be worse here but here
neither for Queen g5 takes takes takes
and my Queens attacked which is sort of
problematic
I mean maybe here and here I have to
play queen g6 I think there's also a
queen f5
let's play queen g6
yeah night before so first impression
was queen
h7 yeah I'm really going all out for
this attack forgetting about the center
forget about my Bishop died miss Queen
h4 earlier maybe I had Queen h4 but then
g3 be a problem so he plays g3 here I
like to play each - there's Queenie for
ideas at some points yeah let's start
with h2 preventing king h2 and now
there's Bishop h3 ideas as well gosh of
h3 it's also g5 ideas g5 Wow I mean g5
takes takes takes Bishop there I think
I'll start with g5 because the Knights
controlling a lot of key squares I just
want to get rid of it and then vision of
h3 should come next like lights words
can be very very weak combination of
this and this and this and also Rick t8
on the horizon this bishop has been
hanging for so many moves and he finally
takes it so we're trading I'll be down
what like a pawn I'm only down upon it's
not too bad so I'll play Bishop h3 Queen
f3 so played so quickly I could take it
I don't really want to take it my bishop
should be stronger than everything can
move
hmm I think I'm gonna castle
time is running low I think that bishops
more valuable than the rook diagonals
just so you see I want to do this in
this also see choose hanging randomly so
maybe I just take it at some point
okay so takes and Bishop a5 I [ __ ]
about five right away I just about five
right away I guess keep the pressure
don't want to give him easy decisions so
he saves a the e4 square I could
continually attack the e4 square I could
take on c2 you just take on C to see
what he's up to
C files still closed this doesn't move
he wants to win h2 I want to win
everything I don't know if I want to
play that still but let's do it it's
time to trade and simplify trade Queens
I'm up the exchange winning upon maybe
f3 rookie III rook F on your key to you
shouldn't be good enough still somehow
holding onto the pawn think I'll do this
I mean e5
and c5 put the rock back on f5 he wants
to win ce7 let's defend like this I'm
like this may 5 b6 I gotta move faster
walk the King up the board don't think
I'm getting mated d3o let's walk up
further let's do this
maybe this venomous walk up further take
a pond take another pond let's move the
rook here trade rooks queen not the
cleanest finish but a finish nonetheless
that was nice
that's some nice like opening
preparation I don't know how sound that
was but I mean I got a time advantage
early kept the initiative eventually won
material all right so I'm playing we
tick again let's play a London again
last time I play them I flagged him with
one pawn such a dirty flag let's play
this line Queen b3 mm-hmm if g6e fourth
that's what's the line here Bishop g5 I
think and this and then I should eat ooh
Bishop f5 is interesting I think I have
to play this threatening g4
so I could take the night's can move
back I think I'll take the night looks
fun
the night f3 how do I play h3 first it's
one out of three if the sign might even
consider g4 looks interesting so such a
weird position but my bishop is kind of
strong but kind of also out of play and
my King is kind of stuck maybe be three
we trade before as I move to ninety five
is a move let's play b3
whoa
85 this could get dangerous
I mean can I just take it so blocks
acting upon maybe you take with a pond
could take your first let's take your
first and this looks very dangerous
because the center is kind of opening up
my king will be stuck kind when another
pond feels greedy but it also feels
appetizing and I'm threatening to take
another pond like c4 is the targets
somehow my bishop is like crawling all
over the board okay he wants to sack and
just win on the spot so let's maybe take
out another pot so many free pawns
I'm up three pawns right now and use
double H pawns the problem is I might be
getting needed at some points okay
that's a move so attacking the knight
maybe Knight B to Glen bishop
efore there's Bishop e6 maybe Knight ft2
kind of defending then we're a fade in
the air I mean I have to do something do
this okay it's kind of scary
there should be six I guess maybe even
f4 looks very very risky hey it's a
hundred bits from its up thanks it's up
I play this tack the bishop okay let's
do this really dangerous position my
bishops hanging I was a really strong
move takes takes I have nine f3
if he takes the bishop I don't see the
immediate knockout blow
I mean blocks probably better here
somehow but he has to prove it I don't
even know what my next move is I can't
play King f2 because rook takes f4
Claybrook b1 maybe
what's his threats
let's play rook yeah rook be one takes I
play this
I think this is under my control so I've
knight c6 here the problem is you choose
a problem Huckabee to stopping mates so
you gonna play Bishop takes III Bishop
takes c3 knight c6 takes takes i when
the recommend should be okay maybe c4
and like I still can legally castle at
some point if f1 isn't controlled 94
ideas well she's going for this I don't
know what's going on here but I hope it
works out for me it might actually work
out has to take the Queen I'm up the
exchange F for his attacked I could push
maybe I give back a pawn I could take
the bishop maybe I should push it's a
bit uncomfortable it's here check there
there oh wait each is defended yeah
let's push saving the pawn down on time
up in material if that let's attack the
bishop well I'm playing 94
try and consolidate maybe got a 96 yeah
I'm okay giving back one pawn I 5 is
strong what do I do here
what do I do
I don't see a move I really don't see a
move rookie - maybe giving back material
not what I wanted really not what I
wanted down a ton of time he got three
this okay let's make him calculate King
runs up I don't know which way my king
wants to run I'm staying flexible
Oh a3 is annoying let's do this
I think I'm gonna come back in time this
is just gonna be a draw I think 10
seconds is plenty of time
[Music]
good game maybe I was winning at some
points maybe not I don't think I'm gonna
catch up to first so I'm gonna play one
more game try and at least finish things
off with a win and well Berzerk what
opening to play let's be fancy Bishop g5
hmm do this I don't know what I'm doing
we're gonna have a Benoni setup though
play h6 kick the bishop I'm gonna
conclude f5 because why not
while castling queenside I feel like
this is a good position to attack on the
queenside like my bishop my pawn chain
my knight I'll sack the nice cuz why not
Bishop d7 may be coming he's gonna sack
on g5 no Queen b6 let's start slowly
maybe this move then Bishop f5 ok where
is my attack night there
want to play b5 at some points I'm just
being very reckless in this position it
might pay off let's play let's go go
back with a knight may be naive for
coming yeah like my minor pieces are
coordinating look at this so beautiful
maybe this move wait a minute
I want my queen like HH how do I get
there still takes a little bit of work
could maybe sack the rook
[Music]
okay I'm gonna be solid for a move I
think the idea is king oh he takes a
free pawn so I'm gonna play King g7 I
want my queen here to attack me too okay
we can trade treats Bishop there I take
here so I want a pawn such a crazy
position whoa
is not expecting that the files opening
and now things are happening big things
are happening look at this this is so
wait is this mate check King d3 is wide
escaping King bee - lets play Queen a -
going after c4 if King here maybe Bishop
c3 maybe not though King D - I take on
b2 queen bee one Bishop c3 is double
check
AHA the rooks attacked so Bishop c3 what
is going on
can I take on d5 takes takes takes takes
takes can take c3 I don't see what else
to do let's do it
hope it works out
this is not good though that's not good
either
let's do this I'm down so much time wait
let's take a free bishop Karina five
Kings g7 I still have King safety kind
of counts defend no Queen trade
expecting rook DG one maybe see four
ideas
rugby two ideas first and then c4 check
spy check for the win
stopping Queen f5 move back I was a good
move Queen h8 I flagged or the game I
was rough I was so close I wanted to
play b3 here maybe I should play b3 I
forgot that
like after a b3 I forgot I'm threatening
a rock a1 because let's say some random
move like I initially saw this in night
a3 I thought White's defining that I can
just take and meets b3 probably with a
bit I better try
I wanted to play b3 here to the prom is
king d3
I miss just a crazy line like this this
I've here here I check oh he can take on
b3
he takes here this is me so that would
be nice I should have played b3 sooner
one more game
losing steam next game will probably be
the last game that was a fun game let's
try and make this game fun I'm gonna
play gambit whatever my opponent plays
it's a gamble against Carroll Khan I'm
gonna try and gambit somehow like after
three maybe it's the only gambit I could
think of play Bishop c4 yeah we're gonna
make this fun Bishop at five
yeah this is already starting to look
kind of fun I'm not sure for who so I
have some open files let's do this
castle 95 coming
if I'm getting anything here rook takes
off five Queen h5g for some options I
think I'll play Queen f3
so not threatening anything g4 h 4 takes
takes know I could take that 5 and then
no that's just bad let's play this try
and keep some attack all my t16 mine see
me on youtube now you see me on Twitch I
deserve to this game
I've okay I have a bad position and I
have low time but I have the most
important thing which is hope but how do
i okay I'm just gonna like bring pieces
and hope things work out can i sack
probably not I don't know what I'm doing
let's play rook here we'll trade nights
still some pressure
I take on u6 I might go for this plan
he's just trading good strategy so tack
the Queen I'm going for this
Queen g3 coming probably h5 while let's
play this attacking the bishop wait a
minute
takes takes a hat doesn't quite work
let's double up
maybe g4 ideas Grob style h5 ideas maybe
this idea what's going on what is going
on all in threatening this and the
bishops pinned and the pawns pinned I
have no idea what's going on
I've 37 seconds so am I just meeting I
think I'm just meaning look at this he
can't stop me
I can even pre move this I'm winning yes
Bishop f6 want to move I think we'll end
it there that's a nice way to end things
this is winning I gathered in nowhere I
don't know if that opening was epic it
kind of went rolling but I don't know
what kind went right in the end
nice easy way everyone is easy ah
so essentially we played a a Blackmore
Deemer yeah so it went from Carroll Khan
to Blackmore Deemer I forgot there's a
fantasy variation of Carol Khan where
white plays f3 in this position now
Knight f6 is actually a good move and
this is something which can come from a
beerus off where if I take then there's
ePHI very strong for black
because takes takes and Blackmun's upon
back so I gamma did suffer I just want
to see this final move Bishop f6
computer any defenses mmm White's
winning +8 man that's insane
there's only winning move - oh there's a
few winning moves h5 also winning yeah I
mean did what I had to do so I think I'm
gonna not play any more games maybe I'll
answer some questions are you playing
any over the board turned in soon uh no
but I'll be it over the board
tournaments I'll be the US Championships
coming up heartwise a new rule with a
thousand bits
thanks heart wise removal you just
arrived you've been watching I
appreciate the bits okay so I'm pausing
the tournament why am I not playing us
champs my ratings a little bit too low
to play US champs you have to be you
have to be like top hundred in the world
basically or you have to win US Open I
think this is a young the strongest US
Championships ever in history like we
have so many players above 2,700
why don't you play or why don't you join
a protest League I played pro Justice
League the last two years this year I'm
still helping out the Webster windmills
and we qualify we're playing the
playoffs next week against the Marshalls
so I'll be doing commentary for that
waiting to hear what time the the round
will be how do I calculate like that
experience it's not always about
calculation sometimes it's about
intuition your instant my Instagram link
doesn't work is it from the twitch page
you just have to search for like Eric
Rosen photography wonder if the link is
broken Instagram there's an Instagram
command in the chats that should work do
you think there's a link between
meditation and chess improvements I
don't know about improvement per se but
there's definitely a link between
meditation and being in a good mental
form during a tournament which can in in
some sense like help you improve like
your tournament play so yeah like when
it comes to preparing for a especially
over the board tournament there's a lot
of non chess factors which play a role
in affecting your chess game on so
meditation is actually it's not for
everyone but it's an interesting thing
to try to just have a clear frame of
mind I've done it during like a few
tournaments sometimes it's hard to like
get the habit down but then on top of
that just eating and sleeping well why
are there so few simple black openings
on DVD /downloads I just recorded a
course on an aggressive repertory for
black I'm also pretty simple Reppert
tour again c4 which should be coming out
soon it'll be on a new website puzzle
rush today probably eventually I did
puzzle rush when I woke up like right
when I woke up and I like I thought I
would be really like slow but I was
I was doing decently but it wasn't the
best score ever best way to improve the
middlegame
mmm there's lots of ways the middlegame
is a vast category of chess one of the
best ways to improve any stage of the
game is to like look at the games of
strong players and see what they do what
kind of meditation the headspace app I
think that's a simple way to get started
like download headspace and it's free
for like a lot of the meditations I
don't play euchre someone tried to teach
me once in high school but then it was
it was terrible in high school we were
playing like my friend was trying to
teach me euchre in the cafeteria and
apparently like card games are banned at
my high school are they were banned so I
like discouraged gambling so I never
learnt euchre are you close to GM norm
I've been close a couple times
I mean it's about tournament performance
so you have to be in the right form and
beat good players or draw good players I
do play poker not as much as I used to I
new play
well I make videos about English opening
yeah the other day I played like a bunch
of English openings I'll probably put
that on YouTube pretty soon I know
there's more questions there's a lot of
questions man if people want to ask me
questions because I've been getting a
lot of private messages and it's just
it's overwhelming but I have a discord
and I have like a channel in the discord
for AMA I've been replying to almost
everything so people can find my discord
I just type exclamation point discord
and you can ask me anything
okay time is it's 1:29 anyone to read
who hammer is playing GM hammer was in
the chat earlier admiring my amazing
mates so his name GM jl h alright so the
link for discord is in the chat
yeah enjoy hammer stream he's playing
chess big surprise hammer time